Film Courage: Do you believe in screenplay
structure?
Christine Conradt, screenwriter: I do.
I believe in the three-act structure.
I believe in learning the rules so you can
then break the rules but there is an acceptable
structure to storytelling and there is a reason
it works and I think if you can get really
good at that, so good that then you can manipulate
it then that serves you.
Film Courage: What was one of the first books
on screenwriting that you read?
Christine: I think the Syd Field book because
it was required reading at USC film school
but it’s still a fantastic book and I think
I actually still have it in my library.
Film Courage: When you are writing dialogue
are your rules for it the same or it really
depends because of the character or the producer
(you know what they want)?
Christine: It depends.
Yeah, a lot of it is what the producer wants.
But a lot of it is just finding the character’s
voice.
One of the mistakes screenwriters make is
that all the characters sound exactly alike.
You should be able to block out the character
name and know who is talking.
And you can learn a lot about how people speak
just by sort of listening, listening in coffee
shops by how people talk.
People are rarely very self-reflective.
People rarely say exactly what they mean.
People rarely talk in complete sentences.
And so the words we use choose and so when
you think about when you go to say something
there are probably a hundred different ways
you can think of to say it.
Why are you choosing the particular way to
say it and when you start to think like that…and
why your character is choosing to say something
that way and what they really don’t want
to reveal like why will they go to this length
but they won’t go just a little bit more
vulnerable.
When you kind of understand that about your
characters then I think writing the dialogue
becomes easier.
But you have to put that thought process in
to it.
To know what they want to conceal and what
they want to give, I think.
And then you can start working with the subtext,
the kind of stuff that makes all of that flavor
kind of come out.
Film Courage: Would you say that the productions
or the networks that you are writing for are
heavy on dialogue?
Just because I mean the nature of women, we
tend to talk more (especially with other women)
that’s more…we kind of get together and
talk and it’s heavy dialogue.
Christine: I think…well the genres tend
to be heavier on dialogue.
I think also when you are doing a very contained,
like low-budget that has a lot to do with
it too because a lot of times the people are
sitting and talking, you’re in a room, you’re
in a house or whatever so you are sitting
and talking.
But I think making sure that that pacing is
good so it really doesn’t feel like people
explaining things.
That’s kind of the death of dialogue is
when people over-explain and they don’t
know how to weave in that exposition kind
of nicely.
Then it really just kind of like hangs there
that’s not good writing.
So hopefully there’s not too much of that
you’re watching on television when you’re
watching that.
Film Courage: Well just when you said the
tone of the culture has changed, has the tone
of conversation and how you word it change?
Christine: Yeah, I think it has.
I think that, I think that it’s less than
it used to be because I think people want
things to happen very quickly.
Like the 2-minute video versus the 7-minute
video, so they want to get through this ad
the pacing has to be much more quick than
it used to be so scenes are shorter so you
get to the point much more quickly.
I think that has changed over time.